Cool.
All right. Amazing.
Um, so today we're going to talk about
uh one of my favorite topics. I'll let
I'll let Vibob te it up a little bit,
but um we get more and more requests for
this specific topic. And I think it's
something we've been dancing around for
a while. Um but especially last week, I
think there's a lot of people asking,
okay, but how do I do this part? How do
I do how do I how do I do human in the
loop? How do I do human in the loop for
tool calls? How do I do human loop for
these things? And how do I do it in a
production grade way?
Exactly. And yeah, and what Dexter and I
are here to really talk about is
something that you'll see that we
mention all the time is a lot of these
principles when building with AI agents
are not that different than software
engineering principles we've all had for
the last 30 plus years. We're just here
to show how to translate some of these
ideas that seem new into ideas that have
existed for a long time and how to
relate it and then how to use all the
tooling that we already know and love
and not have to reinvent 50 new vocab
words just to use AI because in the end
it's all really just
software. Um, and today's topic is one
that like Dexter said is very popular. a
lot of people started mentioning it
because this seems to be the real
bottleneck
uh for a lot of systems. When AI
hallucinates a lot, what do you do? You
toss a human at it because a human can
help out the process. It's kind of
similar to what we do in regular
processes. Whenever you have a process
where you're like detecting uh failure
rates, you toss a human at it. You add
more process to your process and
eventually you have a sequence of steps
that makes it more rigorous.
One way to make model sequences really
rigorous is to put a human in the loop
uh and then have a human go and evaluate
the system in some ways. So some of the
stuff that we'll talk about is really
about software architecture design
today. And I think one interesting thing
that we'll note is there's very little
AI involved in actually adding a human
in the loop. But you can use AI to make
that experience much much more
ergonomic. And Dexter is one of the few
people that I've seen do this in a way
that I think is
like really does introduce new design
paradigms to the level of
like really a human is a new surface
area at least from my perspective. I'll
let Dexter share his thoughts on it, but
I've always thought about like software
as all about surface areas. So when like
the iPhone came out, we added a new
surface area of touchcreens. When the
iPad came out, we had a new service here
of big touchcreens and those are very
different than small touchcreens. That's
why iPad apps are uniquely designed.
Some games only work on the iPad and
others only work on the iPhone just
based on where your hands are located.
Some games only work on a computer and a
mouse. And these kinds of surface areas
make a huge difference in how we view
it. Same with like TVs. They're just
surface areas for the same kind of
software. When you as a human Well, and
we ended up rearchitecting a lot of
software. so that it could work better
across all the platforms. And we had to
kind of like narrow the generic
interface and push more and more
specialization out to the edge where the
users were interacting with it. Yeah.
And we didn't originally do that. Most
software is just software. Uh and then
eventually to get the 99th like to
squeeze more juice and make it more
valuable from like the 80th percentile
to the 90th percentile, we had to go do
that. We do localization in software.
Why do we do that? It's purely to make
it more ergonomic to certain
demographics of users and that enhances
business value. Same in the AI agent
world. Whenever you add humans into the
system, you're just adding more surface
area that your software has to start
considering when you're going to go
build systems. And I think before we go
do anything, I think we should just
start with a demo today because usually
we start with a whiteboard. But I think
today I want to show people so their
imagination can start up and go do this.
And like I said, Dexter has built tons
of these tools. Do you want to show one
of the tools off like the demo uh you
were working on, Dexter? Oh, you want
you want you want to open with that? Um,
yeah, we can do that. The best way I
think people should just see possible.
Okay, cool. I'm going to show you kind
of like what we're going to work
towards, which is um kind of a thing
I've been like dancing around for a
while, which is like how do you how do
you create agent experiences that aren't
locked into the kind of chat GPT style
workflow? Um, and I think the most
asynchronous, most likefi interface that
we can work with um as um almost as an
exercise, I don't actually expect a lot
of you to go build agents that work this
way, uh but is over email. I build all
my agents to work over email. Um, but
this is an idea of a use case that is
like much more asynchronous. Um, you
have software that's going to get to a
point where it needs to get input from a
human. Um, whether it's get permission
for something or just kind of respond to
a request and then that's going to go to
a human and you might not get a response
for hours or days. And so in that world,
you have to think differently about how
you design your software versus, you
know, if I'm just talking to a chatbot
that I built in Verselai or whatever and
I'm going to close the window and stop
the server and come back later, right?
Like it's only valuable in that
synchronous use
case. Um,
let's screen share. And by the way, I
know all of you can go watch these on
YouTube. So the benefit of actually
being on the call is you can ask
questions, you can hop in, you can you
can make it interactive as you want, you
can guide the conversation. what do you
want to go do? So, go do that. If you
see something, you're like, I want to
pop in, ask a question, raise your hand,
unmute your mic, and just ask. These
conversations are so much more fun when
we actually like guide it in the way
that the audience wants to go.
Cool. Um, so I'm guess going to
share one window for now. Um, so this is
just my Gmail. Um, and what we've done
is,
uh, oh man, let's just go ahead. You
have an AI that works agent, right? Um,
yeah. Yeah. Yeah, that's what it's
called. AI. Yeah. Here we go. So, we
made this agent called AI that works.
Um, and we've given it its own email
address. And I It's got access to a
couple tools. Can you do some math for
me? It's some basic calculator tools and
stuff like this. Um, but we can
basically say, you know, can you add 10
and
12? And what's going to happen here is
this going to cause an event to land in
our server. And we'll get into kind of
how all that we're going to actually re
Oh, sorry. I'm not sharing right now.
Yeah, let's share the whole thing. Um,
and remember all these are the things
that we like to do is we like to use
really really basic tools in the
beginning like add and math because it
makes it so unambiguous
on what tool is supposed to do otherwise
there's a lot of things that can happen.
So if you've been to the 12actor agents
workshop you've seen us kind of build
out these prompts and these prompt
templates and BAML and stuff like that.
And we'll get under the under the weeds
of what that looks like. Um, but we'll
see the model kind of finished here and
said, "Okay, now we're done for now."
Um, if I go to my sent mail here, it's
come back and it's responded to me. And
I can say, you know, can you divide the
result by 12? And one thing I'll note is
we've, as an example of a scary tool
that needs human approval, we use
division because division might explode
if you divide by zero or something.
Obviously, it's not uh but it's again,
we like VBO said, we like to use toy
examples so it's very clear to you all
what's part of what we're trying to
demonstrate and what's kind of like you
can go swap in your own stuff here for
this
later. Does that make sense so far?
Let's see the division. Let's see the
human in the loop. Let's see it do it.
So when this thing outputs divide, we've
got some special logic where we say,
okay, that tool deterministically
requires approval. Every time the model
calls that tool, we need to ask for
permission. And so that's going to call
our deterministic code. And we'll see
our new new new agent. And it's saying,
"Hey, we want to run this." And I can
give it call something out. Um I want to
call something out here. The Can you go
scroll up before you go do that? Oh,
yeah. Um and so in the first one when we
added to add, it just responded with the
sum. It did the tool. It did the math.
And I want to note the LM didn't
actually do the math. We use a tool to
do the math. and the LM created a text
message from that to go and go return.
Now the next thing that we did is we
asked it to go divide that and it used
that context
um to go figure out how to go divide
that and then model in this case it
actually ahead to the same user. In this
case it's going back to the author that
asked them to do the command and asked
them to validate.
What if we wanted someone else to
validate the tool instead?
Yeah, we'll get into that. That's a
great question.
Um, so here's our new here's our new
message. It took my feedback and it's
trying again. So, it didn't do the math
yet and I can say like great. Um, and
then that that will approve the thing.
And someone asked a really good
question. One one more question. Someone
asked a really good question about us.
Can you hit the triple dot? I want to
notice this. There's different ways and
modalities of approval. Dexter right now
is using email, but see that link down
here? We could have just as easily
clicked that instead and done approval
as well. So when you think about
approval or rejection, it doesn't h like
this is why LMS enhance the human loop
experience and don't just like make it
possible, they make it different.
And this is a thing I say all the time,
which is this idea of like we've been
sending emails to users from software
for over a decade now. It's always been
a part of a really important kind of
growth loop. But the call to action in
all those emails is always click this
link and get pulled back into the
software which is a thing that the only
real option you could do to review a
report to see an answer to see whatever
it was. Um you would click the link and
then you would come into the tool and
you would like see exactly what was
happening here and you would say okay
cool here's the thing and I can interact
with it here. Um, now with LLMs, I can
just respond with natural language from
wherever I already am. And so it's it
gives you a way to deploy your software
to where your users already are. And I'm
seeing more and more apps and more and
more founders build really successful AI
apps where someone will log in and
configure it once and then from then on
they just interact with it from other
places. And so we'll see because this
was approved it was able to run the
divide function. Um, and I'm going to
answer the first question of the thread
uh real quick, but um, anything else
quickly before we get into kind of how
we're tracking the state here? I want to
call one last thing out here, which is
Yep. So, the only difference between
replying with human in the loop with
over email versus clicking the button is
clicking the button is like
99.9999% going to be correct. It might
still be wrong because a human might
click the wrong button and there's
process that happen. Right. We increase
our error rate a little bit by giving
the user the convenience of responding
in natural language because the model
can get that wrong.
Yeah. Right. There's a prompt here
somewhere that is classifying the
human's message as an approval or a
rejection. Exactly. So for more nuanced
use cases, you may not even want to
allow human a human in the loop. You may
want to require that the human click the
button manually like releasing your prod
system to like a million users. you and
this is actually something that
Anthropic was talking about with the
model context protocol stuff and I know
we have opinions on this but um they
have this thing that they're working on
called the elicitation API which is you
know we don't want to just ask a
question to the user but we actually
want to give them some specific like
options to choose from and those options
might go back to the LM but they might
also go back to a deterministic set of
code where it's like hey which of these
three really expensive ML jobs do you
want to launch And you want to be very
deterministic that only a human can
approve the launch of a expensive ML
job. Exactly. Um, now we should talk
about the session state and Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. And we'll we'll actually go look
at the trace for one of these
conversations. So we have this we have
this thing that we're using that we're
going to build up to, but basically we
have this thread store interface where
we can create new threads, we can get
threads and we can update threads. And
this comes back to our um concept from
12 factor agents which is like the state
doesn't have to be open AAI message
chain. It can be any object that you
want that you can serialize for the LLM.
And so we just storing this in a file.
We have the JSON one that like the human
can that the that the actual program
will use, but then we also just have the
raw text version. So we got an email
from me to AI that works. Can you do
some math for me? And we have the
inbound message. And then we called the
ad tool and we got a response. And then
we called done for now. And that so
these different tools, the ad tool just
caused us to go do the math and get the
response. The done for now tool caused
an email to get sent. Um that's this
response here, the sum of 10 and 12. So
we're we're taking each of these tool
calls in the loop and we'll go detangle
this and get under the hood and on the
whiteboard in a sec. Um but then we got
another human response. And so when I'm
replying to this thread, the model knows
how to route that back to the right
conversation. Um, and so you have this
divide call and it actually rather than
running the call, we got a human
response. Hey, you got this feedback.
And so at each step along the way, we're
passing this into the LLM and this is
the prompt that the LLM is seeing.
Exactly. Exactly. And I think the key
part here is we actually built some
debugging tools to help ourselves out
here. Like the .txt file is just to make
life easier. It's like here's the latest
state of the message, but theJSON file
is actually the source of truth. Can you
click on that really fast?
Um, which one? The JSON file.
Yeah. Yeah. And I want you guys to
notice some of the debugging work that
we built here to make this easier. And I
say we, this is Dexter mostly. Um, and I
think we built the first version of this
together. Yeah. Yeah, I know. But still,
um, specifically, I want you guys to
notice this. Um, this thing is a time
stamp that Dexter put on there. Why did
he do this? It's because if you're
debugging and you just want to quickly
find the most recent thread, it is
really freaking annoying to search
through all a bunch of UU IDs to go find
this. This just makes life a 100,000
times easier and faster for debugging
processes. And that's just software. You
could do the same if there were no LLMs
involved. You you you and you wanted to
dump you didn't want to write a bunch of
observability. The idea here is you can
drop in whatever observability tool you
want. I think even Bam I might even be
sending traces to the BAML web app. But
the point is is like if you think about
your agents as just this sort of um I'm
actually going to pull the whiteboard
up. Um show the JSON while you do that
really fast and then we'll show the
whiteboard too. One second. This thing
right here is just a SQL table. It's a
SQL table of a row of events. It could
be a SQL table. In this case, we just
did the most simplest backing store
possible, which was a file system. In
the file system, every single thread has
a UUID. Every UID is associated with an
email sender and a receiver I and a sub
and an email ID, right? Email thread ID
is what it's associated with. There's
Yeah, there's some like basic basically
like the the inbound web hook payload
that we're working off of is this
conversation.created object. So there's
like the from the to the subject and the
message. And then if you forward one one
use case we can look at a little more
advanced is like what if I just want to
forward an email to the agent and be
like hey can you do the math for these
people of this conversation or hey can
you create a ticket based on this this
like debate we had on our engineering
thread and then that's just like more
context that you might have to because
that other email's thread ID should be
pulled in but I think the key part here
is a lot
a lot of people view all this agent
state management as complex
But actually instead of even thinking
about as agent stuff, what I would do is
I would purely think about it as it's
just if you had to build a system that
was going to show build stuff on top of
email, how would you store that data in
a database? The fact that an L happened
to respond to it is just a user ID maybe
with an extra metadata saying this is an
agent or this is like this user ID, but
like nothing else matters. It's just I
want to save something that represents
the state of a conversation into a
database.
Yeah, it's good. Um, and I'll just say
like in production we run these agents
and we store all this stuff in Reddus.
You can store in SQL. You can do
whatever you want. This is one of those
examples of like you have this interface
in the state thing. You can store this
stuff however you want as long as it's,
you know, as long as you're keeping it.
Oh my god, VS Code started doing this
lately. Uh, I accidentally click on the
author thing and it's half the freaking
page. Um, and you notice we store it in
JSON and TXT and we do different
serializations because they're for
different people. But we could write
this into a database. We could write
this into a memcache store. It it
doesn't matter. We could write this on
like cold storage iceberg. It it it
doesn't matter. So let's talk about how
this stuff works. Um, so at the core of
our agent is um what we call this like
I'll call it the inner loop, the agent
loop. Um, and this has a couple
different components. And, uh, this
comes straight from, um, uh, let me just
pop into 12 factor agents. Yes. We got a
question. No, I was going to say we can
just pop it. We can show them the
YouTube video as well if they want. It's
basically, and we did all the code for
this in like three episodes back or
something. Four episodes back. Yeah, we
did. We did do all the code. But we're
not going to go too deep into it, but I
basically like our inner loop is going
to be this kind of like fourstep thing.
So we have a prompt that is like tell me
what the next step is. We have a switch
statement which is like okay based on
what JSON the model output for the next
step. What was the structured output?
Then we're going to run some code based
on you know whatever that JSON has.
Usually there's like an enum that is
like the function name or the function
type. Um we're going to store as new
events happen we store them in the
context window. That's that XMLA thing
that we showed you. And then we're going
to loop basically until we get to the
final answer. Um, and the final answer
is just another part of a switch
statement that happens to not that
happens to tell us that the best thing
to do is break out of the switch
statement. It's not anything special
and it's not even actually I would say
like this. So this is what I'm going to
call the inner
loop. And then there's another loop that
I call kind of that we'll call like the
outer loop.
which is okay, we get to our final
answer, we go to a
human and then a human might respond and
push back into this inner loop. Um, and
so the agent might go back in and call
lots of tools. And so the reasons why an
agent might exit out of the loop,
there's a couple reasons. So we're going
to specialize this a little bit more.
Um, and we're basically going to say we
have a couple different kinds of things.
We have safe tools, things like readonly
tools or we say like add, multiply,
divide are all safe, but divide is
unsafe. And so if we call one of our
safe tools, then we're just going to
take the result. So we have like our
initial request.
It's a while loop for now. Just assume
while loop. Yeah. Yeah.
Result. And then we pass that back in
and we say, okay, what's the next step?
Um and so this code looks like okay we
say determine next step we serialize our
thread and this looks like
this is essentially a uh oh that's why
it didn't show up.
Um so you know very simple prompt you
can make this much more advanced. I've
added some of the stuff from the 12actor
agents workshop but you know you're a
helpful assistant. You can give it some
more behavior stuff. The idea is like
when we build this stuff and we ship
this code for y'all to use, we're trying
to give you a canvas to paint on and
give you direct access into the most
important parts of the loop because I
don't know about you, uh, but I can
write a switch statement and I can write
a for loop or I can maintain one that's
already written. And what you really
want to be doing, the thing that's going
to determine the accuracy and the like
value and the magic of your app is how
well you can get the agent to pick the
next step while it's in this loop. Uh,
and so you want to focus most of your
effort there and maintain control over
everything else. Yeah, exactly.
Um, so we're going to run this, we're
going to run this prompt, we're going to
get our next step, we'll put it on the
thread and then we'll do a switch
statement. So, um, we haven't gone
through the customer support stuff yet,
but, um, basically, if it's done for now
or request more information, we return
the thread. Also, if it's a scary tool,
we return the thread. Um, and in this
case, we're not returning any extra
information about why we exited because
we can tell based on, and I'll show you
in the CLI here, basically.
Um, and we'll do a multi multiplayer
demo as well. Um, but in the CLI, we
basically we're going to create a new
thread. We'll run it through the agent
loop and then we look at the last event
and then based on what the last event
was. If it was divide, then we're going
to ask permission to divide and we might
actually go run that function. If it was
one of these other ones, then request
more information for now. Then we're
just going to do this message on the
CLI. So I can come here really fast. I
want to highlight this code a little
more. I just want people to read this a
little bit carefully. I want you guys to
think about one thing that's really
important here. What we're not doing
here is we are not doing some voodoo
magic with some AI framework. We're not
doing something special. We're just
saying that this thread is a thing that
we can analyze because it's an object
that we invented of our own based on the
application logic that we need to use
and we just said get the very last
element of that thread. Then based on
the type of messages we have, we know
that there there are three special names
of messages that we need to handle.
One of them is we know that we're here
because we know we know that it's one of
those because we know we're in the outer
loop. The agent loop exited which means
we return we the agent output a tool
that means okay we need to go to the
human. So if it's a safe tool we just
call it and loop again. Um but in here
we're call this this. Yeah. So basically
the idea is like one of the things you
should take away from this is like
creating the agent. Sorry this one.
Yeah. Exact the Y loop. Yeah.
Yeah, creating the agent and like its
core logic and its set of tools is kind
of generic and reusable, but the way
that the agent operates in the outer
loop is something where you can swap in
different interfaces. And so you can
have a CLI to interact with the agent,
you can have a web app to interact with
the agent, or you can do the demo we
started with, which is like an email
surface area. And we'll get into how the
email outer loop looks like. Um um I'll
show you the once we get done looking at
this code, I'll show also the um the CLI
and what that looks like. And I want to
I want to highlight this thing like all
we're doing here is when we get divide,
we just tell the user this is what we're
trying to go do. And if if I didn't put
this handle this case for divide, then
our app wouldn't work because our inner
loop says divide needs to exit out, but
then this one is not handling divide. So
that's an error that I can build by
default instead of having to go do it on
my own. I just and then I use another LM
to actually detect approval or feedback.
But I don't have to. I could literally
require a explicit checkbox here. That's
what it is. We do like press enter to
approve or type feedback to cancel.
Exactly.
Um so ask human CLI is not quite a tool
that gets called because when you call a
tool inside the loop basically like I
want to this this is one really
interest. So you could have a scary tool
and you could say in the body of this
function I want to say like ask human if
approved then go do it. The problem here
is what happens if I call this scary
tool and then the server crashes. Then
we're in the middle of a tool call.
Let's say the human approves it but the
server never like the server crashes
before we go do it. When I relaunch
this, my context window is just going to
have this thing and we're gonna have to
drop back into this loop. And so if you
want to do asynchronous stuff, basically
for scary tools and for human tools,
anything basically that might take a
long time that you want to be pursu, you
could even do this for safe tools,
although it's kind of feels like
overkill. Um, you want to exit out of
this loop so that you stash this thing
on the context window and you store the
state of like what was the last thing we
were doing. Specifically what you do is
you edit exactly you just save it to the
database and then you do a new trigger
and even calling it outer loop is
probably like might be a little
confusing. What I would say is like the
way I think about this is I just exit to
a database. Exactly. I just store this
to a database somewhere or some file
system. Then I trigger another workflow.
If you're familiar with like AWS SQS or
anything, I basically trigger a second
system that says now from
here send out an email to this human
with this thread ID or the state ID that
I have stored. Then that workflow will
trigger and then that human will respond
and say here's a response to this thread
ID. I save that to my database and then
I just continue onwards. It's the same
as every other sort of process system
that I would really be long term. And
the fact so this is one of those
concepts. Yeah. Go ahead. The fact that
it's an AI is just an implementation
detail. That's the key part. Don't think
of AI as the core part here. It's an
implementation detail, not the key part
of it of how you orchestrate your
workflows. Right? So this is another
concept from 12 factor agents that has
nothing to do with human in the loop.
This is literally just a thing that all
of your stuff should do, which is like
you should be able to trigger your agent
with some programmatic API like REST or
MCP. Again, like there's some email
processing stuff going on the in the
background here, but eventually becomes
an HTTP request. Then when you call a
longunning tool, whether it's a long
long ass workflow or it's just interrupt
or it's human human in the loop or
whatever it is, you're going to pause
your thing. You're going to exit out to
what I call the outer loop, which is
conceptual, right? There's there's code
there. It's just, you know, it's a
different layer of the execution state.
We'll take the whole context, put in the
database, and say, "Hey, we called that
long running tool." And then we launch
the workflow, and when it's done, it's
going to call back to us with uh oh,
this shading is weird. Uh it it's going
to post a web web hook back with the
state ID that we saved to the database
and the result of the workflow. And so
we can use that state ID to pull our
previous context out, push the result
onto it, and send it right back into the
LM. And this works for anything that is
asynchronous. And again, you could do
this for every single tool call you do
if you want to be like really aggressive
with your checkpointing. But if you're
doing long running stuff, this is
absolutely essential. And again, there
are tools like Langraph. There are lots
of different things that let you
checkpoint workflows. You could look at
things like temporal or cadence or
whatever it is. We want to ship really
simple examples so that you understand
the concepts here of just literally just
write it to sub file system. You can
drop in your own database as as you want
to. Exactly. Um and I'm going to I'm
going to address some of the question
that people have. One is this like
local first architectures and CRDT. I
don't know what CRDT is. This would be
async pattern for workflows. Async isn't
the right word because specifically this
is not like async. This is more like
task control flow. What I'm really doing
here is I have a sequence of tasks that
starts off some some way to start this
job. I just also happen to have another
entry point into here that doesn't start
from zero. It's exactly it either. And
you might even post the entire context
window. Other people have done this
where like they push the context window
into the workflow system and say I store
nothing here. It's the workflow systems
job when you're done to send the entire
previous context window plus the result
back in and the cho and the and fact of
these matters are like it's all your
choice based on your design pattern that
you want to go do. So for example, we
all have clicked on mail to links and
most time when you click a mail to link
when you email someone it just opens up
a blank thing but every now and then I
click one that comes in pre-filled with
some subject and body filled in. The
whole point of that is there they don't
save anything into a database. It's all
encoded into the URL and you click on it
and that populates all UI providers for
what the next email that you're sending
out. On the other hand, if you were to
file an issue on our GitHub, then we
have some templates that we save into a
database that you click on that reloads
you and let you start from that
template. And it's the same idea. We're
just saving stuff to a database. Nothing
too complex. It just happens that some
of these things require long form may
wait five days before a human checks
that box. And because a human is
checking the box, not a person, not an
agent or something else, it it may take
five days. It may take two weeks because
they're on vacation. Who knows? We don't
want to have that machine running
infinitely on a spin loop until the
human does it. So we we changed the
software architecture pattern to have
two separate entry points that say save,
serialize, and then continue. That's it.
And I think we need to clarify a couple
things to address some of these
questions in the chat. Um there's a lot
of talking about like should should we
make the AI do an unsafe tool or like by
like basically having a tool call to
fetch previous history from a previous
workflow. Um, and like I want to put
that together with like I don't see
where the tool is made available to the
decision loop. And so by Bob, can we
clear your drawings? Sorry. I love my
drawings.
You're a good drawer, dude. You're um
we're going to put it in the
Metropolitan Museum of Claude.
Um I might uh Okay, cool. So let's talk
about the decision loop, right? So we're
giving this model a couple different
sets of tools. We have the add tool,
subtract tool, multiply, divide tool.
And then we're giving it a couple
different um tools that are like either
done for now or clarification request.
And so we're having the model like kind
of declare its intent when it wants to
contact a human or exit the loop. It's
calling one of these tools, but we don't
we don't treat it like we treat most
tool calls, which is like the model did
a thing, so we're going to call a
function map to that. We are doing a
very kind of custom switch statement
here. We're like based on what
structured object was output, we might
go call a function and our handle next
step is basically just going to switch
over the tool type and go run it. But we
also might just return the thread. And
so let me show you what this looks like
in the um in the CLI case just because I
keep saying I'm going to show that off
and I think it'll make a couple things
uh a little more clear. Yes. Yeah, we
should just run it. That's probably the
easiest way.
Um, so we didn't put anything in. I say,
you know, add 12 and three, then add f,
six to
the
result. I can't spell
and you can you can see what the model
is doing. It's literally taking this. We
all saw what it just did there. Um,
there we go. Gave me the output. Um, and
I can
say now multiply that by and then I'll
just put in some garbage. And so this is
going to call a different type of tool
which is request more information. But
these are both going to have the same
effect which is I'm going to get another
message printed to the console. Never
mind divide the last result by
12. And now we're getting our approval
step.
So, I can say no, use six instead of
12. And then I can hit enter and we'll
approve that. And then I'm going to get
my final answer.
Notice one thing special here. When
Dexter did that, when he when he said
no, swap it out, it actually came back
for another approval because divide is
still scary. It didn't magically just go
and say no. And there's nothing he could
have typed into his code to prevent it
from actually uh doing that because what
it would do is it would actually call
the divide tool. It would it would
update this thread. Then it would say
the next best action is divide no matter
what the the get next thing will always
be divide. Can you go back to your agent
loop really fast? I was trying I was
trying to get the I was trying to get
the thread in there. I forgot we had
that commented out. But you can do the
same thread store thing for observe even
though this is like really a throwaway
conversation. You can you can add that
thread store in um if you want to go
back to the agent loop really fast and
decide. Yeah. Yeah.
Um let's go here. Like specifically what
happened is once the model has picked
divide as the next tool regardless if
it's an update or anything else Dexter
has enforced in his code I will always
require a human approval. There's no
there's no prompt injection ever
possible that does that breaks that
right. It's it's just not possible. It's
always deterministic. That's 100. It's
just code. It's just software. We've
enforced in the software that this rule
exists. So there's no risk for divide
happening by accident because the only
way divide can be triggered is it goes
through here. Step back out to the outer
loop.
Yeah. It goes through there. We return
the thread. Then we ask human CLI which
is piece of software that we wrote. Just
named that. And then here we ask the
human via CLI approval to go say yes for
sure. And only if the human actually
approves it will we run divide. So you
could do this for example for refunding
a customer order. It is not possible in
an automated way to send a customer a
refund back. So no matter what happens,
no matter what prompt injection happens,
it will always go to someone in your
support team to actually hit the
checkbox before money transfers over
back to them. And you can enforce this
in a guarantee.
Yeah. Um, we could even give that a
shot. Do you have the email thing
working?
Yeah, that'll work.
Um, process refund.
And by the way, so this one is actually
not going to be with the user that we're
talking to. This is going to be with the
um with some third party. This is
another like uh multiplayer example
basically. So let's let's do this from
the ground up. So we're going to add a
tool. We're actually going to remove
this because we had this request
approval from manager which is again
non-deterministic. It only happens if
the LLM tries to do it. Um but let's add
the refund tool here.
Um, and we need a order ID and and
things like that. And then we'll pop one
step out to our agent loop and we'll
say return it for human approval. And
then in process refund, we're actually
not going to we're not going to ask back
to the person we're talking to. We're
going to do to a different person. Um, I
think we have task manager. Yeah, that's
almost
it.
Um, yeah. So, this is going to ask the
manager and um we can do it over email
or we can do it over Slack. I did get
the Slack thing working.
Um and then what is this supposed to
[Music]
return? Um
manager response and then you do some
filter approval probably.
Yeah. So, this needs to return an
approval.
We have some new type stuff in here uh
going. But let's see what type is
this. Okay.
Huh? It'll make me feel better if you do
or or false instead of exclamation mark.
Fine. Vertical bar. Yeah, there you go.
Yeah, there we go. Okay.
Um, great. So, if it was approved, um,
we'll do that. Otherwise, we will return
that the user denied it. And in our
handle next step, we actually need to
handle that process refund now. So if we
actually if it actually is approved and
we pop back into like we use run this
function in the inner loop um we will
just push uh you
know refund process successfully.
Yes. And notice that we're just
controlling this. We're not using an LM
to generate the response. We didn't do
anything. We just we're just dumping out
that the refund uh processed
successfully.
Um, yeah, we're not actually doing the
thing, but this is where you would
actually go process the refund. And then
I think that's it.
And try to run this. We'll slow back.
We'll There's another type that you have
down below.
Yeah. What's going on? You have to I
think
I don't know why. Why is that failing?
Oh, you can't call some.
Yeah, it's Oh, you know what it is? cuz
we have this block twice. Yeah, exactly.
There we go. Okay. And you want to
delete the responsing at the top
probably. Yeah. Yeah. And agent.ts has
an error as well. Type systems are
great.
Yeah, they fix everything. Um, and I
want everyone to notice the reason that
we know what this
is.
Um, oh, you got to return the thread.
The reason that we know what this is,
can you go to the process refund tool
definition uh in your uh prompt really
fast just in the BAML? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
So, we just added another cool tool
called process refund. That's it. It's
just another data model that the model
now has availability to itself. And you
can see type line
22 and that's all we did. Now this tool
that we have determine X accept used to
have human tools or calculator tools but
now has another tool called customer
support tools to process refunds. We
just added one more and you can actually
you want to zoom out. You actually see
this. Yeah,
you can see this in the prompt now. It's
saying you know we put in the user input
and then um what should the next step
be? So we can even test this with um a
little test, right? Just write one. I
don't have one ready. Oh, there we go.
It actually did it for you. Nice. So, we
can run this and we'll see. Okay, cool.
The output was, hey, we need the reason
for the refund and the amount to be
refunded. And so, we can assert that we
can write assertions of like, hey, okay,
we expect the intent is request more
information here. Um,
let's make another test case. Yeah, we
can make another test case. Yeah, sure.
Yeah, details with all details.
It's for the jeans.
They're too big and baggy. What is this
Gen Z
nonsense? They were
$200. And I think here now we output the
intent process
refund. Um, and now we can say, okay, if
that reason is not good enough, then we
can come back and change our prompt and
be like, no, the reason has to have all
of these characteristics, and we can
write tests around that as well. Can you
add that to description on line 17?
Um,
the
description should be detailed.
Let's see what that does. Let's see.
Depending on the model, it will just
hallucinate a bunch of extra reasons.
Uh, must be 10 reasons verbatim from the
customer. And can you make it a string
array instead of a string? I'm curious
if that makes it I'm curious if that
ends up. Yeah. Okay. But then we're
going to run this thing. But this is
like the popping around different parts
of this. And now notice that didn't
actually give me 10 reasons. And there
might be nothing I can do in prompting
world to make this better. So what I
could do is I could in my code assert
that reasons length is at least 10. And
if it's not I change it to a request
more information request
programmatically in my
code without actually relying on you
would
say you know like handle neck.
Exactly. Exactly.
And so this is why it's so valuable to
have control over the internals and the
transition and that uh as we call it the
boundary between the LM based code and
your deterministic code and to be able
to take yeah now get rid of that
nonsense and actually change it back to
just like reason being a string because
like I think this is the whole point
about human loop systems like this human
loop system is really related to a
couple of things but it's not just about
just like how do you go do The point is
control everything and then you can make
the app do whatever the heck you want
with plain software. Yeah. And human the
loop just becomes yet another way to
transition control flow between this
tight inner loop where you're calling
tools to external systems. And because
we own the thread the thread structure
and how we do the events and how we
serialize this and move this around.
It's just
software. All right. Should we try to
run this? You think it's going to work
on the first try? I think so. I think
so. I mean, that's the beauty. Like,
type systems usually solve most
problems.
All right. I need a refund for jeans.
They're too big. What is this? Gen Z.
That's funny. So, it said process
refund. Um, yep. So, now it should email
you, I believe. I
think, let's see. I'm going to check
also.
here. Here we go. There you go. So,
agent support agent needs approval for
call this thing and I can say like can
you ask them for is this was this one
from just now or is this old? Yeah,
that's the right one.
Okay. What color the genes were
first? And so I can reject this and give
it feedback. And we can go and look in
our thread here and we can go inspect
what's happening.
And then it asked and then it came back
to the user. So it's already come
through this. It saw that we we passed
this context window. And what also
becomes really cool is we can just turn
these into test cases really really
easily. And so if I want to change the
behavior in this
case, make this a
test. I can quickly just pass this in.
And we assert that the intent is request
more information, which by the way is
exactly what happened here. So, it's
asking me what color they were. Neon
pink. And then it's going to come
through and try
again. And we can come through. And
again, like we're using human layer to
manage this Slack stuff. Um, I think
that like most of what we do at human
layer is open source. I think that the
thing of like wrangling Slack web hooks
and moving information around like this
is not a fun or interesting part of the
job. And so we want to solve that. Um,
but I can pop in here and now I can
approve this. Um, but you can send this
via any email API, any Slack API. You
can implement this yourself. This is
really all meant to just be conceptual.
Exactly. Um, cool. Refund has been
processed. Yeah. And now notice here
what we did. We just we literally
triggered the message that the refund is
done. And the LM actually made a nice
prettier message for the user from
refund done to a nice substantial
message that's custom to their needs for
the genes. And then it added a nice
little helper text cuz like feel free to
reach out as well. And we and we could
have again could done all this not over
CLI over the customer's email. And the
whole point is the customer could have
initiated all this over email. We would
get our emails on our approval request
in our system. So a manager is approving
it and we go do that. But we all know
how to build that as software. The fact
that we could have built that
independent of LLMs
means that we could have we we are
simply just doing the same thing where
instead of writing the stuff on our own,
we're just doing it with pure software
here. And what I think Anub asked an
interesting question, where does human
layer come into play? The whole point is
at some point if you want to go
integrate with humans and like have
humans be a part of the system, you're
going to have to build something akin to
pedag duty at some point. Uh, from what
I see of what Dex has built, and I don't
know Dex can speak for himself, but like
that's just a lot of code you have to go
own and maintain. And like Dex has just
built some really nice CLIs and SDKs to
help you integrate and manage that
system. So like if you want to escalate
from the support agent down to like the
manager, you're going to have to build
that control flow out into your
dashboard, you're going to want to have
built an audit trail. You'll want you'll
want to build Slack integrations. You'll
want to build email integrations. You'll
want to you'll want to build text
integrations and human layer just makes
that easy so your code looks simple and
you get to just can you show the HL send
yeah there you go create function call
that code that he has yeah so this is an
ask manager where we basically you can
configure your channel of like where you
how you want to contact the person
whether it's email or slack or whatever
it is and then you can do this like
fetch human approval and we also do in
the server when we get to the done for
how you can use human layer to kind of
like append a message as your like final
answer to the thread and wait for a
response.
It's kind of just like it's just an SDK
to help you increase the surface area of
ways that you can communicate with your
app instead of having to write all that
code yourself. You can add the surface
area of email. You can add the surface
area of Slack. You can add the surface
area of text etc so on and so on. You
can add the surface area of permission
management of escalation flows etc.
Does any questions today uh about how
how this system works and like how we
leverage humans as tools and how by I
think I think it might be I'm looking at
the question. I think um I I think it
might be worth just popping back to the
whiteboard and kind of finishing what we
were sketching out here. I can find that
window. You want to text me a link by
the way? Um, and while if people have
questions while we go do that, if people
have questions and want to hop on and
ask a couple, that would be uh very open
right now.
Yeah, AJ, come on.
Uh, yeah. Um, I'm just wondering if the
human loop event loop can change the
prompt. Uh I'm just I guess just uh from
an architectural perspective I'm just
wondering what the relationship between
the BAML file and the agent plus human
in the loop plus tool call is. So uh is
there a way
during the human in the loop pause to
update the prompt of yeah the family
file. Um that's remember your prompt is
just like variables that you pass into
your code. So, one thing you could do is
the the text file that Dexter made is
just like a Can you show the text file
of your current system that you have?
Yeah. Oh, the um the thread. Yeah. Yeah.
We could eas like this is a UI that
Dexter made in some sense. This is a UI.
It's text file UI, but it's a UI of the
current state in our agent dashboard and
we could build our own UI that renders
the JSON blob or the database entry in
the format that we want for our users.
And then what we can do is we could let
in the approval process instead of just
doing a checkbox yes or no we could
literally just let the user let our
people edit the prompt or edit the state
and that gets passed into the message.
We could have them check a box on the
state. Right? Can you go back to your
JSON blob?
We could add more metadata into other
than events of like add add really
strict prompt in the thread object. Like
we could have more metadata into here
that we have. We could have less
metadata. It's like strict prompt and
like boolean true or false. And we pass
that into the actual like prompt to go
modify it. The way that we serialize the
prompt is really exact. And now we
trigger a totally different workflow.
Maybe exactly determine next step or
something. Yeah. Right. Or it's like you
know determine next step think harder.
Yeah. Exactly. Like it could we could
just trigger a totally separate prompt
and maybe that or you can do something
like uh you know a lot of people have
like working agent right and then it's
like you know we have our success agent
if you want to do multi- aent systems or
something you can have a thread and then
each agent gets its own thread and you
can fork these out and so you can put
whatever state you want on here and this
is again this is another one of the 12
factors I'm not going to it's uh unify
execution state and business state which
is basically like
This one's really short. You can watch
the video, but it's basically the idea
of like just the thing that manages the
workflow and what stage we're in and
what's next and how we're operating can
be the same as the thing that tracks the
data we're passing to the LM. And this
is the thing Vibb talks about all the
time. We talked about in the first like
episode back in March is like you should
build an object that you control and
create different views into it for your
code, for embedding models, for humans,
and for LMS. Yeah, but this is kind of
the core of your application and if you
embrace this then you can do so much.
Yeah, this is literally why in BAML we
if you go back to the agent function
definition why we don't abide by any of
the structure. It's like who cares about
chat roles? Who cares if it's a user
message system message? Some LMs do,
some LMS don't. All we care about is
this is a function that happens to take
in this thread and returns one of these
types. How we implement it might be LM
specific. It might be totally weird. Who
cares? None of us really care about that
implementation detail. Or I mean at some
point we do because we need to increase
our accuracy, but from a user
standpoint, people that use these
functions, they don't care. They just
want to pass in a thread and get one of
these types out. And I think what's
beautiful about kind of like the Bamy
way of making agent is it it actually
forces you to write a little bit more
code, but you own the code and you can
do a lot more interesting fancy stuff,
which is again like what you want when
you're chasing performance. I think this
comes from like the electrical
engineering background maybe is you want
as many little points in the workflow
where you can change things and tweak
things and learn about what works better
because you're dealing with systems that
are nondeterministic. Yeah, Derek has a
question. More questions. Let's go.
Thanks. Um you really got me going with
the jean scenario and the hot pink. Um,
so I'm imagining, okay, first it's got
to classify maybe as jeans because they
could have other product lines. So there
could be access to like the product
merchandising hierarchy. And then I
thought of fraud detection loops like
they might say a color and you're like,
"Oh, we don't sell that color." You
know, it could be flagged for human in
the, you know, review as a follow-up or
something. And then the other thing is
like in any kind of customer service
this idea of a paro chart of the
frequency of each and then you can kind
of assign a cost to the the units in
each uh
bucket that's like a dynamic feedback
loop to improve your product what's
causing the root issue. And so this has
the opportunity to accelerate that. If
all of a sudden there was a bad batch
and something happened uh you know this
would be an earlier alert to that. And
then also for convenience of the user,
if you start to see this distribution of
these are the three or four that like
90% of people come in, you can give
checklists or something like that that
become dynamic. Are these reasonable
scenarios or am I totally like out on
Yeah, 100% of what you said is totally
possible. Can you go back to your outer
loop code decks where you're handling
the agent response?
Yeah.
like um where you get a message from the
human
the human response. Um, oh, sorry, where
you Yeah, this one. Like right over
here, we could run like in this case, we
just save stuff to the state and we move
on with our life. But we could easily
look back into our database and say like
what's the skew ids that match this and
that can be another function whether
it's an LM embedding or just regular
code that looks for the IDs for that
customer ID. Like maybe we do a lookup
of the customer ID based on the email or
the phone number that's under the
message. We look up the details. We look
at their last purchase and we're like,
"Is this the purchase you're talking
about?" And like flight companies have
done this forever. Whenever you book a
flight and you call them, we're like,
"Oh, are you talking about this flight
that's coming up?" And you just say yes
or no. And they can do that because they
just associate your phone number with
your data. We could go do that same
thing here. We could save more metadata
and we could we could query our SQL
database or in this case our file system
database for all the things that were
returned in the last 50 days. And we can
just analyze that totally offline in a
totally different process that we run on
batch every day, every hour, every three
hours, whatever we want to build some of
the analytics that you're talking about,
Derek.
Um, deterministic or something here.
Exactly.
Did you have anything to add to that,
Dexter? Was that
No, I think that makes sense. I mean, I
think I think you're getting the core of
it. It's just like it's all just code.
And so if you own the loop and the
control flow, then you can shell data
out to other systems whenever you want,
you can pull data in. It's not that you
can't do that if you're using kind of a
more blackboxy framework that kind of
like wraps up the loop for you and just
like calls functions without kind of
giving you hands into the guts, but um
it definitely becomes a lot more clear
and you can I don't know, I think we're
in the age with LMS of like I think uh
somebody in the Ruby community wrote
this back in like 2014. It was like
duplication is better than the wrong
abstraction. Like having way more code
that someone else has already written is
better than having an abstraction that
gets in your way or makes things more
complicated. Exactly. And also like code
you than code you don't own. Especially
in the world of AI where everything is
changing so fast.
Yeah. All right, Obby, what you got?
Yeah, my question is like in in this
flow, how many agents do you have u or
how can we have this uh human in the
loop system in a in a group chat with
what we have in AG2 or autogen or um
like a swarm kind of chat where there
are multiple agents communicating with
each other and at every step you want
the human intervention Um, and you know,
like if it's how do you because you
can't really terminate a chat and say
like um maybe you can terminate the chat
and uh do that but you can't really pose
uh a a workflow with uh with multiple
agents working because then each worker
that gets paused during the uh the
system like imagine thousand customers
uh using multiple workers and how how
any things that are on hold. So like how
do you how do you uh I kind of n
I think the confusion that you're uh the
the place where your question is coming
from is from this premise of how these
systems are running. You're running all
these systems in a black box by these
other frameworks that basically run
while loops under the hood. Yeah. Okay.
Now the problem is you want to go and
stop them and those frameworks don't
really give you a good way to stop them.
Exactly. Exactly. And uh the only way I
can think of is you know uh if if it's a
group chat have some human intervention
but uh basically end end the group chat
and start a new request instead of boils
down to the same thing that you have to
do. What you have to do is you have to
somehow serialize your state. At any
point you should be able to view the
state of the system that you are
running. The reason that most people run
into problems with these systems is
you're not able to view the state. Think
about how you do parallel tasks today.
Instead of viewing it like an agent,
just view every single one of these
boxes that Dexter drew on the left as a
No, that one. The other one you were
doing. Can you can you go back?
Yeah. Oh, sorry. Zoom. Yeah. The the the
one with the web the web. Yeah, that
one. This stuff that Dexter wrote over
here. Each of these doesn't matter if
it's a Y loop or not, right? All that
matters is that as long as they're
running and I can introspect them and
have some way to serialize the state,
the state of my system now just becomes
a serialized state of all of these
together at any given time. And in a
multiprocessing job, I'm going to I'm
going to delete my drawings. In a
multipprocessing job, how do I go deal
with this? Well, I build this way to
communicate to each of those workers to
pause. I pause it and I do a sync step
and I tell them to exit their loop.
That's how you do multi-threaded code.
So if you want to do multi-threaded
code, you got to do multi-threaded code.
You tell each of those workers to stop.
You get their state, get them to write
it into their database. And you have to
deal with atomic variables. And you have
to deal with locks and contentions and
all this stuff that we have to do in
multi-threaded code. That doesn't go
away. You just now have introduced that.
The point is is that if you if you if if
the if the internals are a black box,
then you don't even have the option to
go write that code. Exactly.
That's kind of why like if you're using
Swarm, you're kind of I don't I
know Swarm specifically, but like any
most of these frameworks that own the Y
loop and don't let you touch the Y loop,
you're basically because you
can't go and stop. You can't go in and
stop the loop. So, you just have to wait
until the loop is done. Yeah, that's
what I said. you know, like have the
human intervention agent at the end and
end the entire group chat and maybe
somehow store the history in a database
or something and do another request. But
this is what my other question is, yeah,
go ahead. But this is what Dexter says
so much is like if the only benefit
you're getting from there is just
running the Y loop just write the damn Y
loop and now you can just like that Y
loop whenever you want to whenever you
want to leave and that will make your
life a lot faster and easier.
My other question is like why do you
want this? I know people always talk
about like I want multi- aent systems
and my question is always why and I'm
not saying that useful Dexter sassy
way threading is useful
right like I run multi-threaded code all
the time it's part of I'm talking about
multi- threading though I'm talking
about like I guess I guess like the
model and like message passing and stuff
like that exactly like message passing
and running multiple channels in your
codebase like Go is based on this as a
programming language go is literally
made so we can just send data across
channels really fast and really easily.
Uh it's made a whole design pattern
around this because you do write this
kind of code all the time and agents
might benefit from this kind of code.
But I think what you're saying is that
highQL agents are probably good for 95%
of developers because 95% of developers
don't write multi-threaded code anyway.
So just write the code that you're used
to writing instead of trying to blow it
up into like a multi-threaded system
most of the time.
I guess makes sense.
Um I want to come back to kind of a
little bit like just just one more thing
that I wanted to get across. Um is kind
of like something we've been hacking on
and thinking about a lot which is um
kind of like after having designed these
systems for a really long time. Um we're
kind of working on a this is a preview
but we're talking about like the agent
to human protocol basically where agents
can either contact humans or request
approvals. And in this one like the
input is a message and the output is a
response. And then so this is like a
basic restbased API and then you also
have events from a human. And so your
agent can like fire something off and
pull for it or you can fire something
off and forget about it and wait for an
event. Um but we have these kind of two
different classes and then this
conversation created one. Um so you have
function call which is like the you know
request approval call this function
call. Uh, and then you have human
contact, which is just like string to
string either whether it's like request
more information or I'm done for now or
I need clarification or whatever it is.
Um, and those can come into your agent.
But that's that's kind of just like to
close the loop on that server we were
building basically. Um, and this can be
a million different humans. This can be
the manager, the CS
manager. This can be the user you're
talking
to. This can be a hundred different
things. But this is this is a thing
we're thinking about a lot and um trying
to trying to figure out the right
interfaces for um and this is the kind
of stuff that like I think this should
be open source and this should be open
protocol and this should be like a thing
that everyone can like use and get to
and build together which is why we're
building it in the open. Um and then
this implementation of like how to get
in touch with humans on Discord and
Slack and Microsoft Teams like no one
should write that code. That's
just a pain in the ass. Yeah. And and I
think the key part here Oh, you stopped
screen sharing. You want me to pull it
back up? Um Um Yeah, pull it back up.
The key part here I think that we'd like
to talk about is like the stuff over
here is going to be useful regardless of
AI. Like the way if you had to build a
process management system where you had
to have a human and your customer
success bot uh talking at the same time,
like customers and your customer success
agent, you're going to have to go design
this system anyway. The fact that an LM
triggers it is just an implementation
detail. Like that's the key part to
think about. The LM triggering this is
an implementation detail. And the thing
I think that confuses people the most
about LLMs is they treat them like a
magic new thing. But LLMs are just
functions. They take an an input, in
this case a thread, and they spit out
one of the types that we want. And we do
things based on types. And we know how
to deal with things that spit out
different types like unions. We have
built a lot of software that deals with
unions all the time. So like once you
think of it that way, it becomes really
easy to see what what to do here. And
like all the stuff on the right of that
is useful regardless of AI. Uh VJ has a
question.
Yeah. Hi. Uh first of all, thanks for
giving me this opportunity on this
platform. Uh I'm kind of new to this so
please uh forgive me if my question
seems naive or basic. I just wanted to
add a thought to what you said by that
uh
um it's basically a way to input
nondeterministic
uh feedback or inputs or variables or
whatever into your business flow. So
what you've even demonstrated just now
is basically uh a business logic or a
way of defining control flow. Uh which
again my my question was whether how do
we draw the line between how much
portion of your software is going to be
deterministic and how much of that is
going to be agent driven. But I think
that was not the right question to ask.
What was the right way to ask is or the
right perception is to actually just
look at it as um getting a paragraph or
a text or whatever or random input which
is nondeterministic versus filling a
form of or a page or a CRM or whatever
and then just processing it as usual the
way you do it uh in your one. Exactly. I
think that's like one use case for an
outl but I think like you nailed it.
Yeah. The way that I've always thought
about this is like LLMs are just an
accelerant. Like we could all make Slack
take less than 70 gigs of RAM by writing
in Rust and making it really damn good.
But it turns out no one cares that it's
an Electron app that takes 70 gigs of
RAM. So why write in Rust? And it's the
same with an LLM world. Like, hey, if
you you could have someone type out the
business form and go do that manually.
Or you can use an LM to turn like voice
into text with some voodoo magic with a
video in there into the form. Great.
then go do that. Especially if it gets
you to ship faster, even if it has a 20%
failure rate, because it might be better
to ship in two days and get to
production with a 20% failure rate than
to build it out for 9 months perfectly
with some LMS and your own custom models
and some control flow and then not know
it whether it works or not. And LM are
just another tool in our software
engineering toolbox like a boatload of
RAM or bigger GPUs and bigger CPUs that
you can just use to accelerate your
development cycle and like product
iteration
speed. Yeah, I think that's great. I
think
um and and I think this is another
lesson I learned over a long time was
like a lot of people say, "Oh, AI is
here. We're going to do agents." And
they kind of take whatever their project
is and they start a brand new that we're
going to do agents. We're we have our
SAS, we have our product, we have our
tool, whatever it is. Now, we got to
pull it up and we got to build agents
and we're going to start from scratch.
We're going to make these seven agents
and I have to jump in and be like, "No,
like the number one concept, the thing
that LM are really freaking good at that
creates magic is turning unstructured
data into JSON." And that unstructured
data might be JSON or XML or whatever it
is, but it's like turning anything into
JSON because your code can do something
with JSON. And that's where the magic
is. And you can pick up these small
principles like how do you bring humans
in or how do you do your control loop or
or how do I construct a prompt? You can
do all this stuff in the middle of your
existing code. And because and because
it's already like the best LLM apps are
mostly just code anyways. You should
just start sprinkling in more and more
magic as you go rather than throwing out
the whole thing and be like the way we
do software has changed and we're going
to do this kind of software now. Like
it's all still mostly the same. If you
if you look at any of the like founders
building AI agents that are making like
a 100K plus in revenue, it's all mostly
code. Yeah, AI is a small part of it. Uh
AJ, last question and then we're going
to close it out today. Uh yeah. Um my
question is just I guess zooming out a
little bit and more just on business use
cases. I wanted to get your um thoughts,
both of your thoughts on sort of
uh I I don't want to call it emergent
phenomena, but just sort of emergent
things that you've noticed as a result
of building these human in the loop
agents. Specifically, the question that
I have is whether or not building human
in the loop agents has allowed um your
customers or those people that you're
servicing to better map those
non-written understandings that exist um
in their brains but not uh from the
documents that they're that you and your
agents and your tools are calling. I'm
just trying to get a sense of what like
emergent behaviors are happening as a
result of having human in the loop.
I think people are willing to give
agents access to more risky things. I
think people are willing to actually
build agents that um that do interesting
important stuff that you would never
give an agent. I mean like we have users
doing it sending emails on behalf of
them to their supply chain suppliers and
logistics. I've seen people building
agents that manage Terraform applies and
like there's all these use cases that if
you went to any IT manager in the world
and you said like hey are LM smart
enough to like spin up and tear down AWS
infrastructure they would say like
absolutely not keep an LLM as far as far
away from that stuff as possible. Don't
even think about touching it. And now
we're seeing people ship developer tools
where it's like, "Oh, well, if the agent
hits me up in Slack with a Terraform
plan and I just review it and I can give
feedback like, oh wait, wait, wait,
don't upgrade EKS. I was just trying to
add a DNS record that can go back to the
LLM, it can change the code, it can come
back and suddenly you've created this
kind of like flipped workflow where
rather than me opening the SAS app to go
ask an agent to go do something for me,
the agent's just always working in the
background and coming to me and I feel
comfortable giving an access to scary
things because I know deterministically
I have required that that agent is going
to have to go to a human. A human is
going to have to click a button. There's
no prompt. There's no question about it.
a human has to click a button in order
to actually uh push that thing through.
And I think VJ said something kind of
interesting here. It's like I will move
my money if a bank views an agent in its
core loop. And like we say that now, we
do say that now, but I want to pose a
paradigm shift that has happened before.
Um I used to get a text message before
every single time a credit card swiped
on every dollar value that it swiped on.
And now I get a text message every time
I swipe over 500 bucks because like it's
just not worth me thinking about uh how
every credit every time I buy coffee I
need to approve it. That kind of sucks.
And like while today we feel that way
about agents moving stuff. It's possible
that as we all build trust and it
doesn't even matter about the capability
of the models. It's all about trust
building and how software is architected
around these systems. Like we didn't
used to touch trust digital banking. My
parents never trust that a check could
be deposited over a phone and taking a
picture of it until like they saw it
happen for a long time. And some people
will build that trust sooner. Some
people will build that trust later. But
the way we can we as engineers can help
build that trust for everyone is by
building software that works. By
leveraging AI in a way that is reliable,
trustworthy, and engaging, we'll earn
the right over time to get everyone else
to use our software stacks and have
agents do stuff with less human in the
loop. But still, some stuff will
probably want that. Like before I close
my bank account and it has a million
bucks in it, I want to know that the
bank account is being closed and no
matter what, no matter how many agents
there are, uh, ever happening. Yep. Um,
so I think it's just like a paradigm
shift that'll happen over time slowly.
Yeah. And it's continuous, right? You
start with like I mean even that refund
request workflow, we'd be like, "Hey, if
the amount is greater than $10, then
check with a manager otherwise just do
it." And you've seen if you've asked for
a refund from Amazon, you know,
sometimes it's just like, "Cool, here's
a refund." like too small for us to care
about. Yeah. Um this was super dope
everybody. Thank you so much. Vibbov,
thank you so much for uh helping helping
make this happen. Um Nico says hello and
then we will What's up Nico? We will
come back next week with another session
that we'll announce pretty soon. Um
excited to see you all next week. Thank
you for joining today. Uh another fun
time of AI that works with Dexter.
Super dope. Thanks everybody. Bye
everyone. See you.